the accolades keep pouring in for dr
fauci oh our beloved exalted ruler dr
fauci
not sure if you subscribed to instyle
magazine perhaps not
but if if you haven't then you haven't
seen dr fetchy's beautiful spread
where he's sitting by his pool he's got
oxford
shoes on for some reason kind of dad's
sunglasses
just sitting there looking cool looking
in style
it's called the good doctor dr fauci
says this i kid you not this is the
headline dr fauci says
with all due modesty i think i'm pretty
effective
pretty effective 120 some odd days
after we were told 15 days to slow the
spread
well don't worry if you missed the
instyle cover because you can watch
opening day of the gnats that's right
the washington nationals
are going to have dr fatchi throw out
their first pitch oh isn't that so
wonderful
that's after after their wonderful world
series win
they are going to honor dr fauci this
you know
to me this doesn't seem like how we're
supposed to treat scientists
this seems to me like how we treat
celebrities this seems to me like how we
treat
politicians but this is not normally how
we treat
scientists that's because science has
strongly overstepped
its bounds science has failed and in the
face of the failure i don't know how you
look at this coronavirus situation
as anything other than an absolute
failure you could look at it
as a little bit of a political attack as
well
but in the face of all that we give our
honors
to dr fauci we will take a look at the
real story
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
show
[Music]
dr fauci gosh i can't wait till i get my
instyle
magazine cover i don't know if i'm ever
going to get that i try to be stylish
but they don't i don't know they don't i
guess i need to
i need to screw up a national epidemic a
global pandemic then
maybe i can get my cover i do have to
get to the question i asked yesterday
which is
now that he's back who should be kanye's
running mate this i think was by far the
best answer
uh kanye should pick jeb bush as his vp
i don't know why it just feels right it
does feel right
it feels right because it feels so wrong
you know it's just it's like how could
you make the year any crazier
kanye should pick jeb bush and then
we're right back to where we started
you know we went from the bushes to
trump to it's even crazier than that is
kanye
and then the craziest thing would be
kanye picks a bush and it goes around in
a circle again my question for you today
she has been called the naked athena
what do you think is the best nickname
for that naked portland protester who we
will get to
in uh in just a moment after we skewer
dr fauci and before we skewer dr fauci
by the way
do have to thank our friends over at
lifelock you know
criminals they uh they don't
particularly care what's going on
okay actually they care what's going on
in the sense that they will exploit
what's going on
to steal your information okay you've
got to be responsible
lifelock detects a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number
for sale and the dark web if they detect
you that your information has
potentially been compromised
they will send you an alert if you
become a victim of identity theft
lifelock
can help you restore your identity
easier than what you can do on
your own i trust these guys i
really really believe in lifelock
obviously no one can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses
but lifelock can see threats that you
might miss on your own join now save up
to 25
off your first year do that by going to
lifelock
dot com slash knowles k w l e s
that is lifelock dot com slash knowles
for 25
off head on over there right now
lifelock.com
knowles so dr fauci has this
cover and he says in all modesty i feel
like i've been pretty effective
i guess he he has been effective in the
sense that
his constant urging
has forced america to shut down even
though his predictions
has been to have been totally wrong and
his guidance like when he told us not to
wear the masks and now he says we have
to wear the masks
has been extraordinarily contradictory
but it's been effective in that we
really are we're locking down again
right
dr fauci took this a step even further
into the land of the absurd when he went
on pbs newshour recently
and when he was asked to kind of compare
how various states have reacted to the
coronavirus
he decided to tell us that the state
that has handled this thing the worst
has actually done it the best we have a
problem we need to admit it and own it
but we've got to do the things that are
very clear that we need to do to turn
this around
remembering we can do it we know that
when you do it properly
you bring down those cases we've done it
we've done it in new york new york got
hit worse than any place in the world
and they did it correctly correctly
i assume means they did it by sending
very sick people to nursing homes and
killing all the senior citizens that's
i guess that's correct it's only correct
depending on what the question is i
suppose what you're trying to do if
you're trying to kill all the old people
then that would be the correct solution
if you're not trying to kill all the old
people then you probably shouldn't do
what new york did i also love this logic
here which is
we know for a fact new york got
got hit the worst right but
the the line between an event that
happened to new york that new york had
no control over
and new york's participation in that
event
seems to be a little blurry here for dr
fauci
it may be the case that new york for
whatever reason would always have gotten
hit worse than any other place
but couldn't new york have been prepared
on the ventilators
they weren't couldn't new york have then
when they ordered more ventilators
gotten the number they needed right they
didn't they vastly overestimated how
many they needed
couldn't new york have gotten its
estimates on who needed the hospitals
correct rather than set up an emergency
hospital at the javits center they
didn't need and call in the federal ship
that they didn't need
couldn't new york have not sent sick
people to nursing homes
yeah i think they could have done that
couldn't new york have
not had its politicians encourage people
to go to the chinese new year parades
at the outbreak of the virus yeah they
could have done new york did everything
wrong
the democratic politicians in new york
did everything wrong
and this guy freaking dr fauci
who also got everything wrong this guy
has the audacity to come out
and say that they got everything right
we should follow them
i have to tell you i've tried to be nice
and
circumspect about dr fauci he's got a
hard job
i'm kind of done with fouchy i think
we've had enough fauci
fauci got us to this point
which is 120 days after we were told
this thing would be over
15 days to slow the spread that she got
us to this point where he's given us
contradictory guidance
on what we are now told is essential and
essential element of
preventing the spread namely the face
masks fauci's gotten us to here
which is uh chaos and rancor and
economic collapse
and vastly overblowing
the the numbers that he was shooting for
maybe we try someone else
is dr fetchy the only public health
official in america
what happened to dr burks dr scarf bring
her back or anybody else
i think we've had enough dr fauci you
know the president was asked in that
chris wallace interview said
mr president why are you criticizing
fauci and he said oh no we're not doing
that i mean he was wrong about
everything but we're not doing that so i
think it's about time
to lean into those instincts as well
there's there are a lot of shenanigans
going on with this virus
i mentioned on the show the other day or
i rather i read
a question that someone said they they
went to
a medical center to get tested for the
virus
the line was too long so they left early
and they never got tested and they got a
phone call and said they tested positive
and they said that this happened to a
friend of theirs as well so i said look
i don't know anything about this it's
just a personal anecdote
then there was that story out of texas
where this apparently happened to
thousands of people
and the government has now gotten
involved because it seems so credible
well i spoke to a friend of mine last
night here in la
same story different cities same story
she went to get tested for coronavirus
the line was like two hours or something
so she signed in but she did not get
tested
and she got a call that she tested
positive
that's just one more anecdote but it
seems like these anecdotes are starting
to add up
what is this is this a system of
perverse incentives here
is this just sheer incompetence is this
something else i don't know
but there are certainly lots of
shenanigans going on with our response
here they've gotten it all wrong
one aspect they've gotten wrong seems so
obvious it's just common sense from the
beginning
and yet from our public health officials
you could never expect common sense
which is that when you lock very old
people up
and keep them alone and away from their
loved ones for
months and months at a time it doesn't
go well for them it's not good for their
health
there's a study that's out now uh
preliminary results showing that uh
since april 85 of older americans
say they're socializing less often or
rarely or never
not surprising we told older people not
to leave their homes
88 said they were not involved in a
community and 41 percent reported
worsening loneliness this according to
dr carla
perezinotto what a great great last
italian last name a university of
california san francisco professor and
geriatrician
she said this in senate testimony
we also know from these scientists maybe
not the other scientists
that living alone without social
interaction uh is implicated in higher
rates of
heart disease worsening dementia
alzheimer's and
death shortens people's lives
i i gotta i was speaking to my
grandmother
who has been locked up alone has not
been allowed outside you know
doesn't go anywhere a couple weeks ago
when church reopened
and she said i don't know i'm very
afraid to go to church but i really
really want to go to church and it's the
only place i see people
and it made me think about this question
what should we tell our loved ones who
are a little older to do
if if if this is actually going to drag
on for a year
as some public health officials have
suggested or 18 months or something
in some cases for older americans you're
talking about the last few years of
their lives
are we really going to tell them for
this last period of their lives
don't go out of your home don't see
anybody don't see your loved ones
i don't think so i think people should
take precautions be responsible
wash your hands even wear the stupid
mask whatever be responsible about it
but i don't think we should condem older
americans to living
the rest of their lives in isolation
away from
anyone that means anything to them i
don't think so i don't think face time
is enough
not that most senior citizens use face
time all the time either
these questions are not questions
for science there's no scientific answer
for whether you should allow grandma to
come see people
in the last years of her life that's a
political question
that's an ethical question that's a
personal question for your family
it's many things but it's not a
scientific question we talked on the
show yesterday
about how what the left has done
is take all of the political questions
that we debate in our free society
and then pretend that there is a
scientific answer for them
so that they can completely cut off
debate this has been
the leftist game since karl marx pretend
that politics is actually science
politics which involves disagreement and
persuasion
is actually science which does not right
science is set there's a consensus
no questioning and then apply that
science to history and say there's a
science of history and it's always
progressing toward the leftist utopia
and if you stand in the way of that not
only are you foolish because history
will march on forever
inevitably but you're also evil because
you're standing in the way of progress
that's the leftist game we gotta shatter
that we gotta stop that i
joked on my show a few weeks ago i said
we have to ban the word science
from public debate i'm only half kidding
we should use the word science as it
pertains to science maybe
even though even that's kind of silly
because the word science refers to all
knowledge it comes from the latin word
for knowledge so the idea that now we've
truncated an all of knowledge into this
tiny little sliver
of material inquiry is a little silly to
me as well but what we certainly should
not do
is use the word science as a stand-in
for politics because we've got
to debate difficult questions where
there sometimes aren't clear answers
where we have to weigh risks
and and offset certain goods with other
goods and
and deal in this sort of finite
political reality
another great example of this in
kentucky a kentucky couple
was just fitted out with ankle monitors
by the local authorities because they
refused to sign a public health
declaration on the coronavirus
so now they're essentially under house
arrest and
they were wearing ankle monitors like
prisoners
they were fitted with this by the hardin
county health department
because the wife tested positive for
coronavirus
and she was willing to be very
responsible with how to even though it's
got a what is it
a 99.7 recovery rate
she was going to be very responsible not
leave the house in quarantine
young woman so she's not really at great
risk here
but she refused to sign one
self-quarantined document which which
said
that she would not get in an ambulance
without getting permission from the
public health authorities
and her reasoning made perfect sense she
said you know if i'm having a heart
attack or something
i'm not going to ring up the public
health authorities and get a
permission slip that i'm allowed to go
in an ambulance before i do it i'm just
going to go on an ambulance
so she wasn't going to sign that and so
the authorities
slapped her with an ankle monitor
it's not a scientific question it's a
political question do we want to live in
that sort of police state maybe some
people do
but if you do have the honest debate
don't hide behind this
facade of science with a capital s and a
trademark over the e
led by that wonderful disinteres
disinterested scientist
who's smiling at you by his pool on the
cover of in style and throwing out the
first pitch at the gnats opening day
these are the stakes of politics right
now the left is actually
it's not even like one issue or another
issue or they disagree with you on this
issue
it's that they want to take politics
away from you they don't
want you to participate in politics
they want not just to silence you in the
public arena
they want to silence you you know in the
way that we debate these issues
they want to silence you in any way
contributing
to our political decision-making and in
the face of that
some worse than useless squish
republicans
are siding with the democrats we'll get
to one very prominent one in just one
moment
first though i gotta thank our friends
over at ring oh ring
how i love ring because ring allows you
to keep an eye on your home
whether you are in your home or at the
office or on a beach somewhere
it makes you feel like you're in the
jetsons and it makes you feel very safe
ring is on a mission to make
neighborhoods safer
their home security products are
designed to give you peace of mind
around the clock from video doorbells
and security cameras to smart security
lighting and alarm systems
ring has everything you need to make
sure your family and belongings are safe
and secure
anytime anywhere with the all-new ring
video doorbell 3 you can keep a closer
eye on things
than ever before absolutely terrific
sweet little lease is a good shot and
everything but when i'm away from home
makes me feel uh very safe to know that
i can trust
ring the other thing i love about these
guys i mention it sometimes
i hope my friends aren't listening
necessarily
i give ring out as a housewarming gift
one because it's very effective two it
makes you feel like you're in the
jetsons three
it's not very expensive so you get a lot
of credit for a great gift but it
doesn't cost you that much
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit when you're ring.com knowles
that includes the ring video doorbell 3
and chime pro it's all you need to start
building custom security for your home
today
that is ring.com knowles k-w-l-e-s
the stakes are very high you always hear
that
this election is the most important
election of our lifetimes
and then you get the next election in a
sense
the people who tell you that are right
because
one election leads to the next election
leads to the next so if things are
getting worse and worse and worse
then every election is the most
important election in your lifetime
this one though i think is a little
different in that
uh roving gangs of anarchists are
actually burning the country down all
around us
so that would they're tearing down
george washington you know that would
seem to be
important and then most distressingly
they are
taking politics away from all of us and
shutting us up on social media
and shutting us up in the public square
and shutting us up as a matter of public
policy
and in that arena
squishy worse than useless republicans
like john kasich
are siding with the democrats john
kasich
his father's a mailman did you know that
seriously
you might not have heard that if you
had your ears plugged up for the entire
2016 presidential campaign
john kasich whose father is a mailman
who lost
donald trump who was governor of ohio is
now effectively a democrat
he is going to speak at the dnc
in support of joe biden next month
there's a funny thing about john kasich
which is that john kasich perhaps more
than any other republican
is responsible for donald trump winning
that nomination when it was clear
that john kasich could not win the
presidential race when the race was
coming down to president trump and a
couple other people
john kasich refused to get out more or
less
cemented trump's victory why did he do
it we all assumed that he had made a
deal with
with trump to be vice president or
cabinet secretary of something but he
didn't
he came out and excoriated trump
afterward but
he stayed in anyway presumably because
it was all about him
it was all about his image it was all
about him getting plaudits it was all
about him getting
nice articles in the new york times and
that's what's happening again
these guys i suppose
in a way we should be thankful that
they're exposing themselves now
because there are a lot of people on the
republican side who pretend to be
true believers who pretend that things
really are pretty bad for our culture
and for our country
who pretend to stand strong for
solutions
to fix our country sometimes at personal
cost
and then sometimes it gets too real when
they are on the verge of victory
when we are on the verge of talking
about political issues that actually
matter
that have not been spoken about by
either party or have not been seriously
dealt with at least
when we're on the verge of actually
doing something
taking on the enormous risk of winning
they wilt
they fall away they say we can't
actually do that they'll talk a really
good game look a lot of us were a little
nervous about donald trump in 2016.
particularly because some people thought
he was a bit liberal and so they'll say
hillary is the worst person ever she's
terrible she's going to run her country
off a cliff she's going to take her
second amendment rights she's going to
take our first amendment rights she
hates the country
she's oh but i can't vote for donald
trump oh my god he might actually win
oh no we can't do that i'll vote for her
instead
the thing that they said was so terrible
and awful
turns out to be perfectly fine when it's
actually
threatened they'd rather play their
roles as the court jesters in the
kingdom of liberalism
then actually win that's john kasich
totally useless republican
no one needs to pay any attention to him
there's another group of people doing
this called the lincoln project
and the lincoln project is even more
ridiculous and self-serving and
unprincipled than john kasich
so funny some of these never trump
republicans the the five remaining
people on earth who are never trump
republicans
they they say that they're principled
they seem not to have very many
principles all the principles that john
kasich said he was fighting for
but in his entire political career until
2016 he threw him out the window
to get nice reviews in the new york
times same thing with these guys the
lincoln project you might have seen it
on twitter
maybe on tv if you watch left-wing news
channels
it's this group that pretends to be
principled republicans they say that
they are persuading
enough disaffected conservatives
republicans and republican-leaning
independents in swing states
actually though they're not really doing
that there's a great expose of them in
national review right now
they are a bunch of unemployable
political consultants
from the republican and sometimes
democratic side who can't get any jobs
now because trump booted them out of
their cinecures
and so they are raising money
exclusively from leftists to do what
to kick trump out of office no to pay
themselves
that's what it is it's a big con
what they they i'm actually i know some
of these people
they spout these democratic talking
points they'll say donald trump is a
russian stooge things like that
which is very funny because one of the
founders of the lincoln project by the
way is actually a paid agent of russia
he's a registered lobbyist for russia
shows you the kind of hypocrisy here
but what they do broadly is they raise
money from democrats
to to fight trump as republicans and
then
they pay themselves they pay their own
political consulting companies
a lot of money listen to some of these
companies summit
strategic communications that's run by
the lincoln project treasurer reid
galen t-u-s-k digital
tusk digital run by former lincoln
project advisor ron
stezlau as of july 13th the lincoln
project paid
at least 5.6 million dollars
to those two companies 5.6 million
they've raised something i think like 20
million so far and they just pay their
own political consulting companies
they did spend 1.67 million dollars on
ads across facebook and instagram
but those ads are just targeting leftist
donors to pay them more money to pay
themselves
they have aired some tv ads you know
where they are tv ads this is a group
ostensibly trying to convince
conservative voters not to vote for
trump they are the tv ads on morning joe
morning joe is a left-wing television
show on a left-wing cable news channel
how many conservatives do you know that
watching msnbc
not very many but they air the ads
to get more donors to pay themselves a
total con
a total con it is a way to use politics
to aggrandize themselves
aggrandize their own bank accounts and
not
not do anything no principle whatsoever
principle be damned and in the face of
that
in the face of these frauds like john
kasich
and like the lincoln project i see a guy
like kanye west
who is a little eccentric a little out
there
probably not fit today to be president
not just yet
at least but i look at a guy like that i
see what he's talking about
i think that guy has a lot more business
in american politics
than any of those frauds kanye west you
know he did his first campaign rally
we played some of it yesterday on the
show there's one bit
that you can't find in a lot of places i
don't know it seems like it's being
covered up by the internet or something
no
no one has clipped it out at least so i
went through the whole rally yesterday
if i
had to go through several versions of it
to find this bit because sometimes audio
drops out at these important parts
kanye west gives a definition of freedom
that is more sophisticated than probably
seventy percent of republicans and
conservatives could come up with
politics america trump
fighting nor khan and west can free us
the only thing that can free us is by
obeying the rules that were given to us
who are promised land
and the freedom does not come from an
election
the freedom comes from you not loading
up pornography
the freedom will come from you not
taking the purpose of it the freedom
comes from you knocked down and your
brother and your sister
freedom comes from you putting that gun
down and that's shooting people at the
gas station
it has nothing to do with this election
it only has to do with god
and god's people
kanye west has given a more conservative
and more precise definition of freedom
than the vast majority of conservative
and republican politicians and thinkers
could
today it's so funny after this rant
that he gave there are many people on
the left and the right who are saying
kanye he's crazy he's gone insane he
needs to get the help that he needs
i see this all over twitter he needs he
needs help
kanye west sounds more sane than
the vast majority of people in our
public life and certainly than than most
people
on twitter what is kanye saying he's
saying freedom will not come from an
election
freedom will come when you stop watching
porn
freedom will come when you stop taking
drugs freedom will come
when you put the gun down and stop
shooting people at a gas station
this definition of freedom is
an ancient definition of freedom and it
is the christian definition of freedom
which says the man who sins is a slave
to sin
coincidentally it is the definition of
freedom that many of our founding
fathers would have understood
john adams who says our constitution is
built for immoral and religious people
is unfit to the governance of any other
kind of people
you need to be a free people to have
free government
it's not the other way the government
does not make you free
the government cannot recognize a
freedom that you do not possess
you have to be free to govern yourself
and what is freedom there are these two
competing visions of freedom
there is the kind of modern squishy lib
weak version of freedom
which is you're born free and then
society
tries to stop you from being free and
educate your freedom out of you but as
long as you get naked and protest in
portland
and do whatever you want all the time
and take whatever drugs and have sex
with
whoever people and eat whatever you want
drink whatever you want just
follow your appetites as far as they can
go then you'll be truly free
that's the lib squishy crazy version of
freedom
the correct version of freedom which is
conservative and ancient
and recognized by our founding fathers
is the idea that actually
you're not born free in the sense that
you
can govern yourself you are born
as a little baby babies aren't free they
can't they're very dependent and then
you are
educated in freedom that's why we have
the liberal arts we educate ourselves to
make sense of our freedom
to tame our passions and appetites to be
as john adams says immoral and religious
people
and then when you can control all of
those passions then you are free
to govern yourself that is a higher
freedom it's a freedom that eludes
virtually everybody today because we are
bombarded
with things that compromise our freedom
and i don't think it's a coincidence
that many people
who have a strong interest in continuing
to compromise our freedom
and bombarding us with things that send
us down bad paths
i don't think it's any coincidence that
those people and and their kind of
lemmings in the public
are trying to call kanye west crazy is
kanye west a little crazy yeah he's
always been a little bit crazy i think
i think most celebrities are a little
bit crazy i think he would tell you that
but ironically the thing he's being
called crazy for now is some of the most
sane stuff
we're hearing on our political scene and
so they've got it the left has to use
that science
capital s trademark over the e to
diagnose him as crazy and shut him up
and
probably send him to an insane asylum
for speaking the truth
they'd like to do that to all of us i
think
luckily though there is a little bit of
hope here
in politics i was talking actually to a
priest
who who said you know with all this
crazy
news stories and floating around how do
you stay positive
and he said i know i know you know our
our savior lives and
the this wonderful faith that but but
politically from a political standpoint
how do you say stay positive
i thought about it that was a very good
question and there is an
answer there is an answer and we're
seeing the fruit of that answer play out
right now we'll get to that one second
first though i've got to thank you thank
you for subscribing to the michael
show youtube channel be sure to hit that
bell and check out exclusive content
posted at that channel like our latest
piece
the best of the worst tick tock videos
also
backstage live will be this friday july
24th
7 p.m eastern 4 p.m pacific also
ben has a new book do i have a copy of
that book here i do
the book is called how to destroy
america in three easy steps the book
goes on sale
tonight at 6 pm eastern 3 pm pacific ben
will be doing a virtual live signing
event that you can't miss and maybe
maybe i'll show up there i don't know
maybe you'll see me there uh
with your purchase of a signed copy you
can write in a question which
may be read and answered as he signs
your book live on the air you can
pre-order your signed copy
and write in your question at
dailywire.com ben and get a reader's
pass one buck
for your first month three bucks a month
after that get a lot of exclusive
content head on over to dailywire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
where's the hope from a political
perspective how do you stay positive
from a political perspective
beyond religious assurances
beyond hope in the next life
it's this issue that russell kirk talked
about in the conservative mind it's this
issue that crops up
even among the most pessimistic
conservatives
which is this reality reasserts
itself in the end that is the great
conservative consolation
no matter how crazy things get no matter
how ideological and delusional and
fantastical
the left becomes and the culture becomes
reality ultimately will reassert itself
you can't urinate on people's legs
and tell them that it is raining forever
eventually
they'll wise up and they'll get sick of
it
today you see this probably most clearly
on the transgender issue
the left is telling us that men are
really women
and that men should be able to use the
women's bathroom
and that men should be able to change
next to your daughter
in the girls changing room some
excitable people on the left will tell
you
that if you are not sexually attracted
to men
who are pretending to be women that
you're a bigot
that's a bridge too far that's just a
bridge too far
the left can delude a lot of people on
for instance abortion
another issue kanye's been talking about
the left can delude a lot of people and
pretend a baby's not a baby
the left can dilute a lot of people in
the popular culture entertainment
culture
sell people a bunch of tripe and tell
them that it's high art they can delude
people that way
the left can get people to go along with
a lot of their issues but it just seems
to me that pretending that men are women
is a step too far
and the numbers bear that out the media
matters you know our friends over at
media matters
they're our private pr firm
they just clip out parts of our shows
all the time and post them all over the
internet we say thank you so much thank
you for the advertising
media matters put out a piece yesterday
they were very upset
the right is dominating facebook
engagement on content about trans issues
they actually name daily wire daily
wears right there at the top
right laning sources earned more than 65
percent of interactions on top
trans related content media matters
study
of interactions on published online
content about trans topics shared on
facebook
found that right-leaning sources earned
higher engagement we looked at 225
pieces of high-performing content
on trans topics which earned a combined
total of 66 million interactions on
facebook
and the content and related topics from
right-leaning sources can constitute
65.7
of those interactions comparatively 15.4
percent of interactions were in by
queer sources whatever that is 3.9
percent from left-leaning sources
10.4 from non-aligned and 4.6 percent
from
other sources and the daily wire
apparently performs
right at the top there on on a lot of
that content
the study goes on and on i recommend you
go read it media matters doesn't get it
they think they think that the reason
that right-wing content
right-wing content on transgender issues
performs better on social media is
because we're gaming the system somehow
we're cheating we're we're doing
something nefarious
do you know why right leaning content on
trans issues
does better it's because men are not
women
and everybody knows that and
right leaning on this particular issue
just means
stating what is perfectly obvious that
men are not women
it's amazing you know i did this whole
speaking tour last year called the men
are not women
tour it was a joke it was a joke because
that's the most obvious thing you could
say you say the sky is blue you'd say
two plus two equals four
but today on the left in the leftist
culture
it's considered controversial to say
that men are not women do you know why
the the right wing content does so well
is because
you can't fool people forever on some of
the most basic
facts of their lives
the right leaning content does better
because
reality reasserts itself in the end
how did donald trump win in 2016. it was
the russians it wasn't the russians
remember we had that whole two and a
half year investigation millions of
dollars wasted
to find out it wasn't the russians it
was the
it was the i don't know the ukrainians
it wasn't the ukrainians it wasn't
anybody do you know what it was
reality reasserts itself in the end you
had the entire american establishment
media
politics administer administrative
government big tech
higher education lower education
everything working against donald trump
and he still won barely but he won
how did he win because people
recognized that they were being
defrauded by hillary clinton and by the
left
if you want your content to perform
better on social media
say true things don't delude people
don't urinate on their leg and pretend
that it's raining
if you do that if you do all those
terrible things you
you will have success for some time
because the left has a lot of power
but in the end in the end reality is
going to
peek through yet the delusions move on
in the media the associated press
has just issued a new rule the
associated press is always issuing new
rules on grammar spelling
how to how to format things you know for
all of the other journalists around the
world
well they've now decided that they are
going to capitalize the b
in black as in a black person
which is a little odd to me i i when i
write i don't capitalize
people's the color of people's skin but
okay that's the new rule they're going
to capitalize to be in black
but they're not going to capitalize the
w in white that's
that's lower case uh
come again why is that why is that
double standard i mean what they're
saying is black people are good white
people are bad
that's really that's all that it means
we're going to we view this
capitalization as a form of respect why
else would they change it
during this period where everyone is
walking on eggshells on issues of race
and black lives matter and if you don't
post the black square you're going to be
ostracized
so they're they're they think the
capitalization is a good thing to do
and so they're not going to do that for
white people even though black and white
are totally analogous right you're just
talking about
people's race and people's skin color
so their excuse here
is that this is according to the ap the
ap
is reporting what the ap said in the ap
the ap said
white people in general have much less
shared history and culture
and don't have the experience of being
discriminated against because of skin
color
uh starting to think we might be having
that experience ap
because you're you're obviously using
this double standard
and and doing so in an insulting way to
a race of people
but imagine imagine what they're saying
here the one the one criticism of the ap
that's coming from the left
is that what they're doing is actually
disrespectful to black people and in a
way i think they're probably right
they're saying white people have much
less shared history and culture so what
they're saying is black people are a
monolith and white people are diverse
and
and varied you know africa is a pretty
big place
africa is much much much larger than all
of europe
but you're saying that black people are
all the same
even though they come from this much
larger continent with all sorts of
varied nations and tribes
but europe which much smaller
and smaller relative to nations and
tribes is
totally diverse the new york times
depends this
they say white doesn't represent a
shared culture in history in the way
that black does
and i assume this also ties into this
discrimination question which i would
remind you we have
one regime of legal discrimination at
this point i'm not saying there isn't
private discrimination that happens
sometimes
surely somewhere it does though i don't
think it's as widespread as the left
says it is not even close
but as a matter of legal discrimination
there's only one kind of legal racial
discrimination that is called
affirmative action
and it discriminates on behalf of black
people hispanic people other racial
minorities and it discriminates against
white people and asian people which is
why asian people are suing harvard right
now it's poor asian people they
immigrate to america they get
discriminated against
then they do well in america what are
they they get discriminated against all
the time
what the ap and new york times are
saying is that there is no white
racial consciousness and they're
basically right
there's not much of a white racial
consciousness pew backs this up most
races have
over a 50 racial consciousness white
people have 15 percent
and when you talk about extreme racial
consciousness it's only about 5 percent
however what the ap and the new york
times and the whole culture is doing
right now
is going to have the effect of raising
that racial consciousness
which most conservatives i think would
like to lower the racial consciousness
we don't think that viewing yourself
primarily through race
is particularly fruitful for
democratic republican politics we don't
think it's particularly important
for our own identity we would probably
prioritize things that are more
religious or philosophical or political
over
issues like race but what the left wants
to do
is gin up that racial consciousness
that's going to get ugly
because eventually people are going to
respond to that
when they say you know if the argument
that the ap and the new york times is
making is that
being discriminated against will form a
racial consciousness which i think is in
part the argument they're making
and then they're saying so we're going
to discriminate against white people in
a way that we're not going to against
other races
what's the effect of that going to be
it's not going to be a very good one but
i think it's the one
that the left actually wants to
accomplish
lots of topsy-turvy politics these days
lots of upside down you know the left
saying they want racial healing what do
they do they so racial division
also totally inverted upside down
the st louis authorities are now
officially charging
the mccloskeys you know the the brooks
brothers model couple the pink shirt and
the chinos with the guns
defending their lives and property
against armed
vandals they're charging them for
unlawful use of a weapon
a felony they're saying it's illegal to
wave weapons in a threatening manner at
those participating
in non-violent protest non-violent
protest the the non-violent protest just
destroyed the mcclaskey's property
their giant gate metal gate
and they were waving weapons in their
face those guys don't get charged the
mulkolowski's defending their own
property
do get charged completely backwards
completely upside down
i hope this is immediately pardoned by
the governor
or laughed out of court by the judge
but i doubt it will be at least early on
because
the whole apparatus is against these
guys it's so it talk about reality
reasserting itself
all of us around the country are saying
you can't hold on if i go on someone
else's property with a gun
and threaten them i'm fine that's a
legitimate expression of my political
views
but if i defend my own property with a
gun i don't even fire it i just hold it
that's a felony you say that's
completely upside down
well it gets crazier there's a piece
it's a true
truly magnificent work of journalism
from the la times
with a naked woman sitting spread eagle
on the asphalt
in portland she's one of these rioters
sitting completely naked
and the headline is out of portland tear
gas an apparition emerges
capturing the imagination of protesters
some people have tweeted they said oh
you know that's pretty nice get to see a
naked lady
i don't know if you guys have ever met
antifa if you've ever seen them up close
i have they're not like the most
hygienic people on earth okay they're
not they tend not to be
supermodels so i think we can only see
this woman from the back but i don't
i i i don't envy the cops who have to
look at this
listen to the headline listen to the
article rather
she emerged as an apparition from clouds
of tear gas
as federal agents fired pepper balls at
angry protesters
in early saturday darkness wow am i
reading like a
reading like a romance novel or
something like that a woman wearing
nothing but a black face mask
and a stocking cap strode toward a dozen
heavily armed agents attired
in camouflage fatigues lined up across a
downtown street
the agents dispatched by the trump
administration over vociferous
objections
of state and city officials are part of
a force that has fired projectiles
at and detained activists protesting
nightly
since the killing of george floyd by
minneapolis police may 25th let me i'll
translate that to you into english
rioters have burned down cities and
attacked people and in instances killed
people
and so the cops are now arresting them
that's it that's you could have i was
that one sentence it was one sentence
that's what's actually happening here
numerous photos and videos posted to
twitter show the unidentified woman as
she halted in the middle of the street
at 1 45 am
she stood calmly a surreal image of
human vulnerability
in the face of an overpowering force
that has been criticized
nationally by civil rights advocates oh
has it
it has been critical the cops have been
criticized
by oh by the la times right for
arresting
rioters okay the thing goes on i mean i
can't
before it was over she struck ballet
poses and reclined on the street
she also sat on the asphalt in a
yoga-like position facing the officers
before they left
wow that is that is a poetic journey it
reminds me of
kennedy's supreme court decision in
obergefell
which read less like law and more like
romantic poetry that reads less like
journalism
more like romantic poetry imagine
imagine that kind of talk
how about how about we just arrest
rioters and people who are
engaged in public indecency like sitting
spread eagle on the asphalt in front of
cops
that's not going to happen that is not
going to happen
at all what we are in the midst of
is a a narrative we are living in a
narrative
that we are told is the truth it's not
just political truth it's scientific
truth
rioter is good cops bad burning down the
country good
building it back up bad george
washington very very bad
leftist marxist activists very very good
we're told this is
eternally true science if you disagree
with it
not only are you wicked but you're crazy
or insane you probably have to be sent
to an insane asylum and we lionize the
politicians who pretend to be doctors
who pretend to be scientists who push
this ridiculous agenda and lie to our
faces
i think science as it has been perverted
has struck out i think we've got to put
that aside at least
until the election and recognize that
the questions that are being posed is
scientific
and the statements that are being posed
to scientific are nothing but naked
politics
naked is that lady sitting spread eagle
on the asphalt
and we need to engage in those political
debates and we need to stand up if we
actually care
about the political principles we say we
believe in we have to do something about
it we have to fight back we have to make
sure
we stand up win the political battle
and then hopefully we can reclaim our
politics
and get back to all the debates that
we'd like to be having
that's our show i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. hey
everybody it's andrew clavin host of the
andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton
you